i think
that there is from a young age as a boy
man
you're somewhat
held accountable from from then you know
so if you do something wrong especially
i'm nigerian so if you did something
wrong you're here with your dad when he
comes home you gotta think so you know
you you're told very early on your
consequences your actions have
consequences and so you need to
make sure that you don't do the wrong
things in order to not have those
consequences but a lot of times
i do think certain cultures don't have
that same energy when it comes to women
and that might be why
okay
yeah i just think
self-awareness in it i feel like as a
man you're forced to have that you know
i mean from early days when you're in
the playground you know i'm saying if
you're fat you're the goalkeeper
it just is what it is you know i'm
saying like you get picked last if
you're not the guy no one complains like
everyone kind of knows like there's
always there's an accountability there's
a hierarchy amongst men like we just
know from early like where we kind of
fit in in it like we live in a world
where
we get shown and told where we are all
the time and what what we are in it and
i just feel like for women there isn't
really that but i think their friends
just lied to them too much
leading on from that as well i think
it's self-awareness
if you're a man and you're short fat and
you're broke the world will tell you as
soon as you enter the dating marketplace
where you enter the world on what your
status is
as a woman if you're if you're
overweight you'll probably have a body
body positivity group say that it's the
right way to be
so i think there's a lot of ways to
mummy cuddle women where there is men
aren't afforded that luxury
well to emulate what the mandom said um
yeah men are forced to have to live in
in reality from young um
girls growing up are just never told no
so they grew up with this idea that you
know the world kind of revolves around
them so
that's why i mentioned that you know men
have to create their value for our life
our women are are given their value
so with that you're afforded two
different mentalities as you're growing
up and going through life and
that allows women to
to operate from this facade of what the
reality shows so when anything goes
against that that kind of
cognitive dissonance there's a there's a
comparativeness to was that
so um question for the women
is is it just me is this just something
that i see where women don't take as
much accountability as men do
or have you seen that in real life like
do you agree do you disagree
um you can start okay i kind of
partially agree but at the same time
there was uh something that the last guy
said that just triggered something in me
like that that's just not true like i
think women do take accountability and
they are shaped
from young as well the levels of
accountability are very different and i
definitely agree
um the fantasy spin
i think is very feminine and they're
kind of like i'm gonna uh i'm gonna
reshape reality i think that is a
feminine trait but that doesn't mean
that both sexes don't have an issue with
accountability i absolutely think that
there is an issue with accountability in
society for all sexes at this moment
where do you see that men don't take
accountability
i think men don't take accountability
for the
the status and um
actual kind of weight that they have put
on themselves and they complain about it
like it's women that have kind of put
this weight on their shoulders and how
they should shape their reality is like
because of women and and women don't
have that same pressure can i think
they've done that to themselves can i
have a specific example i'm just i don't
understand what you're talking about
even just being like okay so i
the role of being the breadwinner or the
one that has to provide everything i
think that is men that have put that on
themselves i don't think that has
anything to do with women you don't
think you don't think that has anything
to do with women when women want a guy
that makes um at least 30 percent more
than them
no i i don't think there are that many
women that think that like that no no
it's if you survey women and ask them
they want a man that makes at least 30
percent more than that
and if a woman one of the number one
indicators of divorce divorces if a
woman out earns the man this is the
difference would that not come from men
100 what would they not be the ones that
are not comfortable no no because
because the women initiate divorce so
women leave is 70 to 80 no no 70 to 80
of the time women leave and 90 of their
college educated so the higher up a
woman goes in terms of income and status
the more likely she leaves okay now
you're saying she's leaving because
she's earning more and no i'm saying
that she may be like i'm not satisfied
in this relationship because
he has an issue with me earning more and
i don't want to stay in this dynamic so
from from what i've seen in the guys you
can maybe correct like you can tell me
what you've seen because you guys you
know you i
making money they're around more men
that make more money than them so i
think
on some level they kind of wish they
were with the men they were working with
rather than their husbands
and so they kind of see what they're not
getting and then they they leave i i i
can see that in some circumstances but i
actually think the troubles in a house
when a woman is earning more isn't
necessarily about that dynamic condition
this goes back to women's women's nature
so yeah we've all heard the term
hypergamy so women are married for
across up social hierarchies so
naturally women are programmed to always
get the best that they can get so at the
time when she got married her man that
might have been the best that she could
get at the time but as she elevates
herself past him then she's in a new tax
bracket with new men who are at a higher
level therefore that her pergamos nature
starts to kick in again and says i can
do better than what i currently have
neglecting that the man in this
situation is also contributing to the
dynamic of that relationship there's
contributing and is acting on it so yes
a man wouldn't divorce a woman
necessarily because she always wanted
him whereas
because
but it may be hell in that and this is
the part that nobody is going into so
should she stay in a house where it's
hellish but this is the thing to have
hold on where are we going because i
just feel like the goal post just got
moved to like to where that is
he tends to be more passive so what are
the chances that he would actually be
raising hell in the house and you also
have to think about this logically as
well if what if we're talking about such
a higher percentage figure of 70 percent
of women leave but the more higher
educated more money they make you can't
then argue like logically that most of
those situations have got the man's
given her health she's doing better for
herself
why is there not surveys on actually the
reasons why the dominant reason for one
is financial and the second is
infidelity yeah so women leave for
financial reasons
and women and men and women and men
cheat at similar rates it's like 23 26
the financial reasons that are cited
could that not literally be that we had
disharmony in our house because i was
earning more
but this is the thing though because you
know or what type financial reasons are
you talking about
the finances aren't enough so she has to
leave and find better because a lot of
times a lot of times women don't like to
have to do more work in terms of that
you know but what what
but what so or the initial question was
you said men are held accountable and
they put that on themselves but what i'm
saying is i think the data indicates
that men are held accountable for this
because if your woman out earns you
she's out the door
so they they men have to deal with a
consequence quick
where where women where if a woman if a
woman gains a bunch of weight in a
marriage which to me is like similar to
the equivalent like usually the men
don't leave i can walk
that what you'll be saying if a woman
puts on weight it's the same as if she
earns more no i'm saying like i think
that the equivalent of a woman a woman
gaining a hundred pounds is like a man
losing a job and refusing to work i
would say it's something
full of attraction instead of what we
are what we're attracted to
okay because we women are attracted to
money money and status whereas men
we're visual creatures yeah
okay so if you take the visual aspect
away from it then
that's when they start treating with
cheating with the secretary and guess
what i can kind of uh see where that's
going i i half kind of agree yeah so
what i'm saying is is women don't seem
to fit like i don't know a lot of men in
real time that are leaving their woman
because she gained weight
but i do know a lot of women that out
earn their boyfriends or their husbands
and leave so what i'm saying is women
don't face the consequence and then men
do